so it's real important with the game
there's going to be a couple of
different terms you want to know there's
gear and then there are appearances so
appearances purely controls exactly what
you would think how your character looks
so everything you see right now is just
my appearance yet if you notice like
this piece of gear I have right here
clearly I'm not wearing that hat I'm not
wearing those types of gloves I'm not
wearing that same scarf these are just
my highest level items so this is how
their transmog works if I go into the
gear menu hovering it here and pressing
X this is how it would change up the
actual gear piece it's like if I get a
piece of higher level gear and I want to
equip it this is where you would go all
these drops that you guys are going to
be getting as well as the house fanatic
robes and the dark arts those are
appearances so you press square for the
appearance and then you keep every every
glove that you've ever gotten you'll
keep it which is pretty cool so you can
sell all the gear you want to sell
destroy it dismantle it whatever